[Music]
[Applause]
dark energy and dark matter I held a
council for 95% of universe the decades
since dark energy is incorporated into
articles we've still sadly got no direct
evidence or existence is it time to
seriously consider meanness that but the
existence of dark energy is nothing but
an empty hypothesis but not one that we
desperately need to make a current
account of universe credible to help us
answer these questions and we have on my
right so be Lusaka head of possible
visit fearing group at the University of
Oxford to my left we have Roger Penrose
physicist mathematician philosopher
around clocks this is left Kathryn
Halen's professor of astrophysics
European Research Council fellow at the
University of Edinburgh based at the
Institute for astronomy is dark energy
just an empty hypothesis and it used to
make up country mr. Caffyn class the
great honour to try and explain what
this term dark energy actually means to
set the scene and then I will answer
your question David so our universe is
expanding so slight and Hubble were
looking at distant galaxies and
everywhere they looked they saw those
galaxies looking to be away from us they
concluded that our universe was
expanding astronomers we're looking at
even more distant galaxies and they
found that not only is the universe
expanding that other expansion is
getting faster it's not going faster and
faster every day and we call this the
accelerated expansion of the universe
now the term dark energy is what we use
to describe what's causing this
accelerating expansion now it's got the
term energy in there because we need
some new source of energy in our
universe to power this accelerating
expansion and it's in front of it and
simply so we can say oh gee
because we're like Star Wars geeks at
heart there's nothing really dark about
it it's quite misleading that whole
concept anyway it's a new source of
energy in David's introduction he said
that there was no direct evidence for
the existence of the self in tonight I
would disagree with you there because we
have a an amazing body of evidence now
since the first discovery in 1998 we
have been targeting universe in lots of
different ways - and all of these
different experiments are coming out
with the same conclusion that the
expansion of our universe is
accelerating now what could be causing
this accelerated expansion I like to
think about these big expanse of the
universe where there's absolutely
nothing and no stars no galaxies no gas
and it's a complete vacuum but quantum
physics tells us that actually in a
vacuum there's lots of stuff there are
virtual particles that can pop in and
out of existence so because we have an
expanding universe that vacuum gives us
energy quantum physics is linking with
the universe on a large scale to give us
this accelerated expansion and it's a
beautiful theory but unfortunately if
the predictions of this quantum theory
are correct
we wouldn't be here our universe would
have expanded so rapidly in the early
stages that the first stars and galaxies
wouldn't have formed and we will be here
and to talk about it and so we have this
entire zoo now of different theories to
explain this accelerated expansion and
they are all under this global umbrella
of dark energy why should you get
excited about it well I focus at the
start we don't understand this huge huge
amount of the universe you could see
that as a major failing of us as
scientists but I see it's a wonderful
opportunity for discovery because when
you don't understand something as huge
as 95% of the universe it means you're
missing a key piece of the puzzle
I don't believe dark energy exists I
believe that the evidence that Kathryn
just alluded to died exhilarating
expansion is a incorrect inference
because
starting the data and that is my
observational belief but I have a
theoretical prejudice and I think all of
us do have prejudices it should be clear
dark energy is not a new concept I think
she suggested it actually goes back a
hundred years in fact when Einstein was
formulating the first cosmological model
shortly after inventing his amazing
creativity he at that time had no access
to data we didn't even know we lived in
a galaxy far less that the galaxies you
know are going away from each other
in fact he based it largely on something
called Marx principle which you are
going to hear which was later dissipated
so basically he chose the simplest
possibility at the time and that's
endless possibility is that the universe
is exactly isotropic and homogeneous
which two namely no it is not and this
universe can have matter in fact at the
time it was called a specialist matter
that's all the new and it could have
curvature space-time curvature is no God
and it could also have because of the
underlying symmetry of the theory that
are delayed general coordinate
invariants it could have something for
the cosmological constant and that
appeared to have an opposite effect to
gravity so in fact because I understand
thought the universe must be static he
chose it to balance the attractive force
of gravity and later when it turned out
that the universe was that should be
expanding here abundant Bethea but in
fact it is not his choice with it to
have this constant or not it is a
property and now well done relying
mathematics is therefore hospital the
problem is this that subsequently we
discovered that the universe doesn't
just have dust at early times it was
dominated by radiation and even earlier
than that it was dominated by quantum
fields and as she just said fields have
fluctuations and these fluctuations
carry energy and if you estimate how
much they contribute to this
cosmological constant it is so huge
compared to the scale of the universe
today so the universe has an energy
scale it's roughly if you like the
inverse of its size
so it's very big universe so that scale
is tiny it is 10 to the minus 4 T 2g GTV
is the mass of a proton for comparison
today we are exploring physics at places
like the Large Hadron Collider at
energies of the thousand T so there is
forty five orders of magnitude between
the two scales and if you follow Raj up
to the Planck scale which is 10 to the
19 GB you have another huge hierarchy
there and our night estimate would be
that all these quantum fluctuations
should contribute to this possibility
constant Einstein says they do but if
they did we would not be here as
scattering oxonium are clearly there is
a big problem here now to me to suite
that problem under the rug and then to
invoke a tiny dark energy which is
actually of the scale of the Hubble
parameter today is simply dishonesty it
is intellectual dishonesty
it is not facing up to the fact that we
have a big problem with understanding
how vacuum energy couples to gravity and
to ignore that and to then use it for
purposes such as driving inflation you
know making the expansion exhilarate
today this is to me not satisfactory at
all so I went to look at the data and I
discovered that the universe is not
really accelerating and all the other
evidence that Kathryn will tell you that
exists is inferred from that simple
cosmological model that Einstein and
others after him proposed that does not
take into account that the universe
today is not perfect it is not
homogeneous
it may be filled with matter that does
not have ideal fluid fusion of stage so
there are many possibilities they're
very complicated it is extremely hard
mathematically to formulate to find
solutions of Einstein's equations when
situation is not absolutely symmetric as
it was in Einstein's theory so I gave
you my watch and Italy that is a biased
watch it
[Laughter]
is the following cosmology is too
important to be left to cosmologists
[Applause]
when he said that the university is not
homogenous do you mean that um we can't
sort of it's not even in spread out as
how the parts of the universe might not
look like this just says okay it's fun
later and follow that logic mentions the
cosmological constant in 1979 you
introduced this term for long will you
say maybe Wes was expanding and he found
the need for this tournament yeah it's
the only thing you can do actually
mentioned without wrecking the sphere
but we knew it was one number but even
though I found them attractive to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas